hopefully the sunny databases the
question is what does this mean and how
do you do it let's try and break it down
into bits okay tables what a tables are
that sorry pause there are two kinds of
databases right simple will complicated
one what do they got that file and
relational now when you hear tables
which one we're talking about a
relational has to be relational right
within a relational database each table
is a little flat file on its own okay
and we used to represent this we still
represent this where they are a
schematic diagram for schema do you
remember that okay so okay and then you
know each table describes a particular
kind of entity and then you have the
different attributes or characteristics
of each one so the idea is that you can
lead tables using these somehow okay so
how would we do this
let me think of an example say um we run
a business and we sell stuff okay so for
instance
I am yeah question when you got a book
on you wrote primer in foreign capitals
oh oh that's exactly confusing okay
should we start again sorry
now suppose I've been keeping my records
for my business and I start off small so
all I just uses a spreadsheet start off
with a flat file okay so for instance I
just um as people come to me I'm like
will they make orders and so I'm going
to put together a table which possibly
know which orders are going where and
gave me the history and make sure I've
got the right amount of body pain the
right amount taxes and so on so for
instance I might have say in whatever
bar over here okay and I say well I'll
just do it in sequence so it's give me a
1 2 3 4 5 ok and then not only do I want
an order perhaps I want to say ok I want
to know who bought this from ok so I'm
going to customer I'd be an online
business ok so obviously I've got to
know where I'm going to send this stuff
to so I'll have an address
yeah ok
and suppose there's a whole bunch of
other fields that tell you about the
actual products that get ordered ok
and so this again it's actually several
attributes over there we're not going to
be interested in I want to focus on this
part over here I suppose as my business
starts off I'm just getting different
people all at random okay so I get
freaky on to something and Steve order
something and orders something and you
know I know what their addresses they
live at number one Kalen foot road
college route oh and I've got other
dresses here and so on ok and it's so
fine so far right but the problem video
when I start to have the same people
coming
actually and giving me repeat business
over ever again
because for instance suppose Ricky
decides the price that I really good so
he comes back you know if you orders
another fee it's like ah forgot about
things so I'm going to put it another
order
okay and you know Steve other people and
I'm going to have the same people
ordering again and again again now can
someone tell me what's the problem in
this scenario
yeah the huge remember redundant docking
okay good so every time Ricky's in here
his address is going to be in here as
well right so one kind of had wrote
elephant I'm coming from calendar every
single time okay and suppose you know I
want to look up okay where where do I
send things to Ricky okay suppose I want
to send him a flyer or you know some
promotion or something like that right I
have to go back and look through where
his addresses but what if he changed
address right and you know some of these
are different to others and I look at
the wrong one and send it to the wrong
place okay so redundant data not only is
it a waste of space
okay but also can lead to these kinds of
problems so how do I solve the problem
well instead of having one table which
is says all my orders in it okay I'm
going to break apart a flat file into
two tables and make it a relational
database right so first I have orders
okay and then I have part of this which
relates which is customers okay so
here's what I'll do
orders I'll still have an order ID right
that'll be one two three four five six
seven okay the next thing I would have
is information about the customer now I
don't need to put their name and their
address every single time okay because
that's redundant so instead I might have
say a customer ID customer five customer
23 okay
now even there I'm already saving space
because just having that number is
shorter than having a full name okay
and then you know there will be some
stuff about the products and so on okay
now the customer ID I look at the order
online customer 23 I don't know who that
is
so in order to actually have some
description here I've got to go over to
this table answer each customer like we
said they have an ID they also have a
name
they also have an address just for the
sake of simplicity let's just treat it
like that okay so let's have a look at
this in the customer table okay what's
the primary key customer ID what is a
primary key after all it's a field right
that uniquely identifies every different
record in this table okay
so I'm going to put my key icon okay
next to customer ID that's the primary
key really so maybe you want to write PK
now it leaks to this table see like so
okay so here in this table customer ID
is not the primary key because it
doesn't uniquely identify every quarter
but it's still a king it's the foreign
key
it's forward because this isn't the
table it really originates from the
originated over there
so you can see having a primary key over
here that's a foreign key or here
that's what joins these two creates a
relationship between them okay now just
for the sake of it since we're at it
what kind of a relationship is it you've
got three choices it can be one-to-one
it can be one savetti or it can be many
to many what do you think one-to-many
who thinks is what to me you know a few
people how can you prove or justify
explain why it's what's a bit
like one customer for copy one customer
can write more than one okay so each
customer can have many orders all right
so there's a committee so it's obviously
not one for one
okay what about orders but the one order
it's one customer I can do okay go ahead
so each order is only going to go is
going to be sent to one person right so
that's why it's not many to many people
right so now which we said you put one
and which one sided we put many on
because my blonde customers attorney on
one goes on customers and many goes on
orders okay you can think about it this
way
one customer has many orders right but
orders only have one customer you see
what that's that's how I read it
okay so that's how you on
that's how tables get leads through
primary informative so I want to ask any
questions to clarify things okay
thumbs up